[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT DUFTLER: Thank you
everybody for coming.
My name is Matt Duftler.
I'm a software engineer
for Google out of New York.
I'm here today with Andy
Glover, an engineering
manager for Netflix.
And we're here to talk
to you about Spinnaker.
Spinnaker is a recently
released open source
continuous delivery platform.
It supports multiple
cloud platforms
out the box, including
comprehensive support
for Google Compute Engine.
So before we dive into the
particulars of Spinnaker
itself, let's talk a
bit about the problem
we're trying to solve.
And that is managing the
complexity of cloud deployments
and cloud environments.
Make no mistake about it, cloud
deployments are complicated.
We talk to customers
quite often,
and one thing we
hear constantly is
that they'd like to
increase developer velocity.
What this amounts to is dealing
with the volume of change.
Terms of decreasing-- excuse me.
In terms of increasing
developer velocity,
the key is to reduce
the friction of time
between developers making
changes and those changes
landing in production.
There are many developers
changing systems all the time,
pushing these changes.
And this is only
going up over time.
As organizations add developers,
the volume of change increases.
And we try to reduce
friction in time
as these changes are
pushed to various stages
in the production.
In addition, you have
multiple services
being deployed independently.
Organizations are moving
to a micro services model.
And as these services
are deployed,
you have potentially
an exponential number
of changes being
pushed into production,
an exponentially increasing
number of changes.
In an ideal world,
changes to these services,
as they're rolled out
or isolated from one
another through a
robust set of APIs--
Still, this
increases complexity.
The volume of change
is always increasing.
There are always more
services coming online.
Also keep in mind, it's
not a static world.
Things are always changing.
You're typically deploying
to cloud environments that
are being dynamically scaled.
And the days when
you can turn off
your service to do upgrades
or make changes are long gone.
So you need to be able
to gracefully roll out
your changes while
you're continuing
to service your users while
your cloud footprint may
be scaling in response to load.
And lastly you need to be
able to revert changes.
So if something goes wrong
as you do these rollouts,
you need to be able to
gracefully and quickly rollback
before you do damage
to your business.
So how do we handle
this complexity?
It's a combination of
principles, practices,
and tools.
The key principle is
immutable infrastructure.
Andy's going to
come up in a minutes
and he's going to talk
about how they employ
this principle at Netflix
using this tool Spinnaker,
which we're going to go into a
lot of detail and show demos.
But first, let's talk about
immutable infrastructure.
So the way things work, you
typically have a machine.
It has CPU resources,
memory, disk.
Some of this is virtual,
some potentially real.
We have that machine layer.
On top of that, you have
an operating system layer.
You have whatever
libraries and applications
your application depends,
on typically something
like an app or a web server.
And then you have your
actual application.
And each of these
different layers
can be deployed onto these
machines using different tools.
Before cloud computing
really went mainstream,
you would typically use
something like a config
management system.
You would use that to
manage your web and app
server, and then maybe
another specialized tool
to deploy your application.
When you would roll
out changes, you
would connect to
those running machines
and redeploy the
application with the changes
onto that running system.
With the advent of cloud
computing and companies
moving to an immutable
infrastructure model,
you would never do this.
The idea is that in
the old days when
it was expensive and slow
to build new machines,
you'd try to avoid building
new machines from scratch.
Now that it's fast and cheap
to rollout new machines,
you're provisioning new machines
all the time in the cloud.
So tearing down a machine,
provisioning a new machine,
installing all of your software,
this is fast and cheap and easy
now.
So when you roll out a new
version of your software,
instead of modifying things
in place, which is risky,
you take the
approach where I have
my new version of software.
Let me bake a static machine
image with that software.
Let me move that image
into a test cluster.
Let me run my tests against it.
Once I'm happy, I stop traffic
from reaching the old version.
Traffic's only reaching
the new version.
And later on, you can go
off and gracefully destroy
that old infrastructure.
Anything goes wrong
along the way,
you can easily roll it back.
Just direct traffic back
to that old cluster.
So at Google, we have tens
of thousands of developers.
It's 30,000 plus developers
changing things all the time.
We have a principle where
any developer can change
any part of the code base.
We have something like a Linux
kernel's worth of changes
landing in production weekly.
So how do we manage
all this change?
Well, we bake new images.
We manage traffic.
We don't modify
systems in place.
Other companies following these
same principles, companies
like Netflix, have been
applying the concepts
of immutable infrastructure.
It's been working
very well for them.
The majority of
their deployments
are done employing
immutable infrastructure.
And the tool they use
primarily to make this happen
is Spinnaker.
And this is their flagship tool.
It's a centerpiece of
their cloud platform.
And Andy's going to
come up and tell us
quite a bit about it now.
And then I'll come back
up and do some demos.
ANDY GLOVER: Thank you, Matt.
Thanks a lot.
It's great to be here.
Is everyone warm enough?
I'm freezing.
So Jez Humble, who
wrote a seminal book
on continuous
delivery, captures what
I think is the essence
of continuous delivery.
And that's about making
deployments boring.
No longer are they
cross-functional scheduled
events that require
a whole lot of people
to get in the same room and
figure out what's going on.
They're just simply done,
and they're done reliably.
And the businesses that
are taking advantage
of continuous
delivery are obviously
seeing accelerated
time to market.
They can produce products
quickly and get them
in front of customers quickly.
And because they
can do that, they
turn out to build
the right product.
They're not waiting a long time
to figure out whether or not
this product actually is
a viable thing for users.
By delivering the
right product quickly,
they're seeing increased
customer satisfaction,
and they're delivering a product
that's of higher quality.
And so continuous delivery
isn't new to Netflix.
We've been doing it a long time.
And in fact we
continuous delivery
as the facilitator for
innovation at Netflix.
We went to the
cloud six years ago
and immediately saw that we need
to start building some tooling
so that we could start
pushing out software quickly
to you all.
And we start with a
tool called Asgard.
And Asgard, in
many ways, captured
the cloud model for Netflix and
maybe the industry in general
in terms of, there's the
notion of an application.
And an application has clusters.
And clusters are made up of
autoscaling groups or server
groups.
Asgard served us well and served
many other companies as well.
And we did those see
that Asgard lacks
some of the real
continuous delivery
features that we needed.
So we embarked on
another effort.
And that effort
was called Mimir.
And Mimir added the notion of
pipelines in front of Asgard,
and thus created a bit
more velocity with respect
to how we are doing deployments.
Around the same time
Mimir was built,
there was yet another continuous
delivery platform built
called Edge Center, which
the Netflix Edge Platform
team had built. And this
was also highly successful
in terms of rolling out
production software to the edge
of the Netflix architecture.
So continuous delivery
isn't new to Netflix.
We've been doing
this a long time.
We've learned a heck
of a lot of lessons.
We sure know how not to do it.
And we think we're pretty
good at knowing how to do it.
And so about a year
and a half ago,
we embarked on a new effort to
create an entirely new platform
from the ground up
called Spinnaker.
And Spinnaker is a hardened,
continuous delivery platform
built to be tier zero for
the business of delivering
software.
As I said, it's
leveraged the lessons
we've been learning for quite
a long time about how to move
quickly into the AWS cloud.
We open sourced Spinnaker
late last November.
And Spinnaker itself is
ultimately a workflow tool.
It has the notion of pipelines.
Pipelines are made up of stages.
After you deploy an
asset to some endpoint,
you also have the ability
to manage those assets.
And Spinnaker itself
integrates deeply
with other operational
systems that
can support telemetry, testing,
and performance monitoring
for example.
And Spinnaker is built-- has
been built in partnership
with a number of companies,
including Google, Microsoft,
Pivotal, and Kenzan.
And these partnerships
reflect a deep integration
with various systems, i.e.
Google Cloud Platform, Microsoft
Azure, Pivotal Cloud Foundry.
And these partnerships
have been bidirectional
from the standpoint of,
we're learning from Google.
We're learning from Azure.
And hopefully vice
versa, they're
learning something from us.
And pluggability is
key to Spinnaker.
Not only are the
assets that you can
deploy with Spinnaker
pluggable-- Netflix has
a very long history of
deploying AMIs, virtual images,
virtual machine images.
But we want to be able
to deploy other things.
Stages of pipelines, they
themselves are also pluggable.
We have our own set of
stages internal to Netflix.
Some of them are open
source, some of them aren't.
Ostensibly other
companies will create
stages that are unique
to their environment.
And ultimately the whole notion
of cloud providers themselves
are pluggable.
And this pluggability
is key for Netflix.
We want to leverage all of AWS.
Previous tooling was
very much centered
around EC2 Compute or Compute.
We want to take advantage
of other services
at AWS like ECS, S3,
CloudFront, Lambda.
All of AWS is a fertile ground
for Netflix deployments,
and we want our tooling
to support it natively.
We also want to take
advantage of CDN deployments.
Obviously Netflix has a very,
very large CDN presence.
And we want to do-- we
want Spinnaker to handle
the deployments to Akamai.
Jars, libs, there are plenty
of teams that their end
asset necessarily isn't a
service that facilitates
watching video, but it
could be some library that
facilitates it some other way.
We want to be able to support
deploying that, that library
into like Artifactory
for example.
And then last but
not least, the system
needs to be flexible
enough to handle the coming
tidal wave of containers.
And the good news is that
Spinnaker supports all of these
through a pluggable model.
As I said, we began Spinnaker
about a year and a half ago.
It's in production
today at Netflix.
And the success of
Spinnaker is predicated
on that it's a self
service platform.
It's got a super easy to
use UI which you'll see,
that teams can go in
and figure out how
to start using it immediately.
They don't need training.
They don't need some
document or manual.
The ability for teams to fashion
their own delivery pipelines--
there is no standard
pipeline at Netflix.
There's a tool,
obviously Spinnaker,
that allows you to create
pipelines with various stages.
But the stages that a
team decides to build
is entirely up to that team.
So a wide breadth of pipelines.
And then last but not
least, because Spinnaker
is open source, we
get to take advantage
of some of the
innovations that you all
are building in your
companies for your needs.
And we've seen that already
today in that pull requests
are coming in, and Netflix
is taking advantage of that.
So it's definitely a
bi-directional relationship.
And that's why we choose
to open source software.
Today, Spinnaker is doing
4,000 deployments a day.
Netflix has roughly
two dozen AWS accounts
with a dozen being
accounts that are
important for streaming video.
Because we have a
standard platform,
people can plug into it easily.
It has a flexibility
with pipelines.
More and more teams are creating
pipelines day in and day out.
And that's leading to
a skyrocketing number.
In fact, before I made
this presentation,
I thought the number was 2,000.
And then our data science
people actually corrected me
and said no, it's
actually 4,000.
So we've seen a tremendous
growth in deployments to AWS
within Netflix since
releasing Spinnaker.
And the beauty of this
pluggable-- yes, there it
is-- the beauty of the
standard platform that's
pluggable is that
everyone at Netflix
benefits from Spinnaker.
When new tools get online,
the first thing they do
is they integrate
with Spinnaker.
And then all teams at
Netflix get advantage of it.
So case in point, we have
a-- a sophisticated-- I
don't have enough coffee
and it's freezing,
so that's my excuse.
We have a sophisticated
automated canary analysis
framework.
That team plugged
it into Spinnaker.
It's a custom stage.
And now everyone at
Netflix get to take
advantage of ACA, a
sophisticated form of testing
before you go live.
Another case in point,
Netflix has a container cloud
called Titus for, obviously,
running containers.
That's plugged into Spinnaker.
Now all teams at Netflix can
leverage Titus for deployments
should they choose to do so.
And as new tools and services
are built at Netflix,
those teams are
plugging into Spinnaker.
And all teams at
Netflix again get
to leverage that innovation.
So I said it was a beautiful
UI and it's easy to use.
And again, Matt will
give more details.
But it's a phenomenal UI.
It's awesome.
And as I said, it allows you
to manage assets in production.
So there's this
notion of a cluster.
A cluster spans the globe.
And then you have server groups
or ASGs inside of a cluster.
In this case, here's a
server group that's being--
it's in US East in Amazon,
and then there's US West.
We codify deployment
patterns, again,
that umbrella of innovation.
Red-black deployments,
which the rest of the world
calls blue-green.
All teams get to
take advantage of
these sophisticated deployment
strategies within Spinnaker.
Pipelines-- this is
the pipeline screen.
This is a pipeline
execution that
shows a series of stages
that ultimately culminates
in a deployment into production.
Spinnaker supports
parallel stages,
so you can obviously
run things in parallel.
You can deploy to many regions
at once if you choose to.
You have deployment
windows so you
can elect to say
I want to deploy
this particular asset at this
part of the globe at this time
of the day.
All in all, it's a very
flexible, pluggable system.
And it's seen
phenomenal success--
I'm having a hard time
here-- success at Netflix.
So I'd like to transition
it back to Matt.
We've been working--
Netflix and Google have
been working together on
Spinnaker for about a year.
And as I say, the innovation
is going both ways.
I'm going to assume you guys
have learned something from us.
MATT DUFTLER: We hope so.
ANDY GLOVER: And we've
definitely learned something
from the Google folks
because obviously Google has
a very interesting
infrastructure and belief
pattern.
So it's been a
fruitful relationship.
So I'm happy to be here.
MATT DUFTLER: Thanks, Andy.
OK, time flies.
It's been a year and half.
ANDY GLOVER: Oh, OK.
MATT DUFTLER: And a half.
So this raises an
important question.
Why is Google
investing in Spinnaker?
We've been working on it
just about a year and a half.
We started with one person.
Now we have a quite
sizable team--
a half dozen or so
engineers, a program manager,
product manager, and so on.
So we are solidly
invested in this effort.
There are the obvious things.
Our principles align,
putting these tools
in the hands of the
line developers,
traceability-- so who did
what, when, where, why--
and relying entirely on
immutable infrastructure.
So these things align, but
there's more to it than that.
Google is actively
engaged in trying
to take things that
we do well internally,
things we've been doing
for a long time internally,
and making them
available externally.
But it's not as simple
as kind of hitting
a giant red easy button and
just making everything public.
We can't flip any
bit to just share all
of our internal infrastructure.
So where it makes sense
and where it's reasonable,
we're participating in open
source efforts like this one
to try to build on things that
are out there that others have
contributed to, and
then get to a point
where we have these sorts
of internal capabilities
available externally.
In the case of Spinnaker,
Netflix is a recognized leader
in the move to cloud, so
it made a lot of sense
for us to get
involved with this.
There are a few additional
benefits which might not
be immediately obvious.
As we've developed
Spinnaker, the Netflix guys
have been sort of battle
testing this thing internally.
It's running in
production all the time.
So A, we can have a high
degree of confidence
that we're not making
breaking changes
because they're
constantly testing this
and applying a
significant load to it.
And B, it brings some sort
of common sanity checks
to any kinds of
changes we propose.
We're not just doing
things sort of as we feel.
We're discussing things.
We're working out in the open.
And then we all agree on
changes as we make them.
And the final thing
worth mentioning
is that the end result is
a product for our users
and our customers
that doesn't rely
on locking into our platform.
It works with a significant
set of cloud platforms.
It works very well with GCE.
We'll talk more about
integrations in the container
world.
But it supports multiple
cloud platforms.
You're not locked in.
The capabilities are
quite similar across all
the different platforms.
So let's leave that there.
In one second, we're
going to do a demo.
OK, can I have the
demo laptop please?
I'll kick this off and then
explain what we're seeing.
So this is a very
simple web application.
I'm going to make
a simple change
so we can see that
change reflected,
and then I'll explain in
detail what's going on.
I changed one local file.
I'm going to change
a version number.
And then I'll explain each step.
I just want to give
it time to get going.
So I have a local git repo.
It has a very simple
web application in it.
It's a typical hello world.
Whatever parameter
I pass to it, it
will echo it back and
put hello in front of it.
I made some change.
I changed it from
saying hello to saying
hello GCP Next, and then
whatever name we pass to it.
And then I did a local commit.
It's a simple application.
But we have Jenkins set
up to poll every minute
or two on that local Git repo.
And when it notices
any change was
pushed to that branch, which
in this case is just master,
it'll kick off a build.
And that build uses Gradle,
packages up that application,
and then produces a deb
package and publishes it.
And we'll look at each of
these steps in more detail.
This particular web
application wasn't built by us.
It was built by Kenzan Media,
one of the other participants
in the open source effort.
So we could see Jenkins
picked up that change
and executed this
build, build number 25.
So at this point-- can we have
the presentation laptop please?
So this gives a kind
of conceptual overview
of the different components
at work, and also
the workflow if we read
it from left to right.
So I'm going to
start at the left.
I'll explain what I
did so far and then
what we're going to see.
And I'm going to try to talk
slowly, which I'm not great at.
But the idea is I want to
let the bake stage catch up.
So starting at the left,
I pushed the commit.
I made a very simple change.
We'll be able to see that
change reflected and tested
in production.
And then I pushed that
change to the local Git repo.
Jenkins picked up the
change through its polling,
builds that web application,
produces an OS package--
in this case, a Debian archive--
and then publishes that
to a repo.
In practice this
can be something
like Bintray, Artifactory.
You have lots of choices.
For the demo, I'm running
a local actually deb repo.
This is a point where a
typical continuous integration
system like Jenkins and
a continuous delivery
framework like Spinnaker
start to intersect.
So we're right now where
the blue shading begins
to the left of that bake box.
So the stuff in the
blue shaded area,
this represents a set of
Spinnaker stages wired together
in a Spinnaker pipeline.
And this is where immutable
infrastructure comes into play.
So when we push a
change, our CI system
picked it up, built
it, ostensibly
ran unit tests-- although
I don't have any-- produced
a deb package, published
a deb package to some well
known repo.
We have an option now.
We could shell into
our running systems,
upgrade that
application in place,
and then we have the
new version deployed.
But that wouldn't be adhering
to the immutable infrastructure
principles.
So what we're
going to do instead
is take a static image, a
hermetically sealed image,
which should be familiar if
you're familiar with Docker
and containerization efforts.
In this case it's a VM image.
We'll package up that image.
Then we're going to deploy
brand new cloud infrastructure,
so cloud VMs with that image.
We'll test those images.
Once we decide
they're happy, then we
can disable or destroy
the old servers.
So why disable or destroy?
If we're done with
the old ones, we
can just destroy them, right?
The idea with disable is its a
traffic management operation.
Instead of just destroying
your old servers,
just arrange it so that they
don't take any more traffic
from the load balancer
sitting in front of them.
This way if something goes
wrong, you can quickly go back.
So make a change.
Push the change.
Build a deb package.
Produce a static machine image.
Deploy that static machine
image into a test cluster,
so a new set of VMs.
Wait until things
are deemed healthy.
And then disable or destroy
the old server group.
And there's a little
bit more to it.
If you look at the top and
bottom-- so we mentioned
it works in multiple
cloud platforms.
The test here is
running against GCE,
so that's really the top half.
So we're producing
a GCE machine image,
and then we're deploying a
GCE managed instance group.
In Spinnaker terminology,
we call these groups
of homogeneous VM server groups.
But it's a managed
instance group on GCE.
If we were deploying an
Amazon EC2 server group,
it would be an
autoscaling group.
Make sense?
So this is what
we're doing, right?
Build code.
Test it.
When you're happy, push
it in through the stages
into production.
So we're taking all
these first class
operations, this idea of a bake,
a deploy, disable, destroy.
We're taking all these
things, and then we're
building a set of pipelines.
And we're using that
set of pipelines
to have a system that
takes source code changes
and pushes them all the
way through to production
in a disciplined
way and leaves open
the possibility of doing
a rollback very easily
and quickly.
So we roughly described
the first pipeline.
So we bake, deploy.
And in this case, if
you're just doing a test,
you can do something
like a destroy.
You're not going to
do a rollback back
in a test cluster.
One thing worth noting
here, we mentioned
we don't have it in mind
to rebuild everything
from scratch.
We're trying to rely on
existing open source efforts
where it makes sense and
build on things that we
consider the best of breed.
The bakery relies entirely
on Packer from HashiCorp.
We built a web
service around it.
But basically it's a
wrapper around Packer
that understands naming
conventions and versioning
and things that are
Spinnaker specific,
but then delegates the actual
work of producing those machine
images to Packer.
So we didn't reinvent
baking machine images.
We're just wrapping
it in something
that makes it a proper Spinnaker
microservice and introduces
versioning and all
the other things
we need for it to
behave properly.
So once that's done, it's going
to trigger another pipeline.
And that triggering
bit is interesting.
If you look all
the way left, you
see that sort of Jenkins guy.
And there's a
picture from Docker.
The idea is you can
kick off pipelines
with a choice of triggers.
There are Cron based
triggers and other things.
But once that
pipeline completes,
we want another
pipeline to kick off.
So that's a pipeline trigger.
So the first one
was a code push.
That pipeline
complete successfully.
Then we have a pipeline trigger
to kick off this validation
pipeline.
For the purposes of
the demo, the pipeline
that does validation
does nothing other
than have a manual
judgment stage that says
validate everything's working.
And then we'll go and click,
yep, everything's good.
Once that pipeline
completes successfully,
we have one final pipeline, and
this is the promotion pipeline.
And this is where it really
gets kind of interesting.
So what we've done
to this point is
push a code change
via a deb package
onto a new set of
machines into testing.
Once we're happy with
that image-- and remember,
it's not the servers we're
testing, it's the image.
Once we're happy that the
tests have passed successfully,
we want to deploy that exact
same image into production.
We don't want to
produce a new image.
We don't want to reinstall
that deb package.
We don't want to open
ourselves up to the risk
that one of the
systems we depend on
has maybe increased its version
or we get a later version that
has some protocols switched off
by default. That's Cassandra.
So we don't want to open
ourselves up to that.
We want to push that
image that we've tested
into the production cluster.
So at that point,
instead of a bake stage,
we use to find image stage.
And you give it coordinates.
You say, go to this cluster.
Find the latest or the
largest server group,
whatever makes sense
for your deployment.
Gather those image
details and make
them available in the
context of that pipeline.
So then any
downstream deploy uses
that image for its deployment.
And finally, if you look at the
end of that last deployment,
we have a deployment strategy.
So this is a blue-green.
The Netflix guys
with patriotism call
these red-black deployments.
Most people call
these blue-green.
So what it's going to do is not
destroy the old server group.
We said in testing fine, we'll
get rid of the old server
group, no big deal.
But in production,
we're just going
to make it so that the older
server group, the older
version of the software
deployed on the old VMs,
just doesn't take
any more traffic.
It still exists.
We don't destroy it.
But it gets deregistered
from its load balancers.
And then if something goes
wrong, we can quickly rollback.
Can I have the
demo laptop please?
We mentioned the
three pipelines.
So bake and deploy to
test is the top one.
The middle one is validate test.
And the last is
promote to production.
So this top pipeline
is executing.
So we had the bake stage.
There's the usual
attributes you'd expect,
what distro to use.
It describes what package is
being installed, what cloud
platform is being targeted.
And that completed successfully,
took about four minutes.
Then we had a deploy operation.
Could render better.
Resolution's a little weird.
So we're deploying that image
that we baked in the bake stage
into the test cluster.
So again, you just
give it coordinates.
In this case, it's GCP
next-test is the test cluster.
And then following that
is the destroy operation.
And what the destroy
operation will do in this case
is determine the
target server group
based on the
coordinates, which will
be just the previous server
group or the older version.
And then it destroys it.
And if we take a look at the
clusters view-- and this is
very much like what Andy
showed, only instead of 600
and a thousand VMs
in each server group,
we really went for it and
have one in each server group.
So I have no backup video,
so I'm playing it safe.
So this is a test
cluster on the bottom.
And if we look here, this is
the newly deployed server group.
And when you click on any
of these server groups,
you can drill down
into the details.
And where it gets
very interesting
is you start to see
the image information.
This is the image
that's under test.
That's the image that was
produced by that bake stage.
You can see it in the execution
details of the bake stage.
And that's the image that we
push into the test cluster.
So we now have a
new server group.
And you can see the old
server group disappeared
while I was talking.
So that was that destroy stage.
And the idea is we
would test this.
So one thing we can
do to test this,
we can click on
its load balancer.
Capture the DNS name or the IP
address of the load balancer.
And that's the
change we've made.
We made it say
hello from GCP Next.
I don't know if that's legible.
If we look at the
production cluster that's
running above it, which is this
one, and we do the same thing.
I have them associated with
different load balancers.
So we click on the IP address
for the production load
balancer.
It has the old style message.
So it doesn't have that change.
So ostensibly I've done more
testing than just click on that
and put my name in.
But we're still going to go
into the manual judgment stage
and said yes,
we've validated it.
We're happy with the behavior
of that image under test.
At this point it's
going to kick off
one final pipeline, which
is a promotion to production
pipeline.
And the first stage
here is find image.
And what this does
is look at that
cluster, which is
the test cluster,
determine what image to use.
And then it primes the
context of the pipeline
with that image.
And this is important.
When you configure a deploy
stage within a pipeline,
you don't put in
image information.
The image information
comes from context.
So if it's something that
was triggered directly
by a Jenkins job
completing, the image
that gets primed into context
is associated with-- I'm sorry.
If you have a pipeline that's
triggered from a Jenkins
context and you have
a bake, the bake
produces an image
using the artifacts
produced from that Jenkins job.
And then the deployment
uses the image
that was produced
from the bake stage.
So you never say use this image.
When you have another pipeline
that has a find image,
it looks in the
existing cluster,
determines what
image was deployed,
and then primes the
context with that image.
And that can be used by
downstream deployments.
But it's important that you're
never explicitly selecting
an image by name to use
in one of the pipelines.
It's always from context.
So while that's running,
we'll go back here,
and we'll see what's going on.
So prior to kicking off
that final pipeline,
we had two server groups
in the production cluster.
So we had six and seven.
So six is now grayed out.
So it's disabled.
Seven is still enabled.
Eight is coming online.
So the server group exists,
but has zero VMs deployed.
So it's still spinning up.
And what it's going to do
when it does this deployment,
we said there's a
deployment strategy,
this blue-green
deployment strategy.
It's going to take
the old server group,
disable it so it doesn't
take any more traffic,
after the new one has
already reported healthy.
So deploy the new one,
wait for it's healthy,
disable the old one so it's
disassociated from its load
balancers.
Then it will do
a bit of cleanup.
And in this case,
it'll make sure there
are no more than two
server groups deployed.
So it'll go and destroy any
old disabled server groups
beyond the one that was
immediately disabled.
That all making sense?
So we'll let that
run, and then--
So we described
immutable infrastructure.
We described some of the
capabilities of Spinnaker,
some of these sort
of first class stages
like bake, deploy,
disable, destroy.
There are the other things you'd
expect, like resize, enable.
You can reenable something.
There's rollback.
There's a host of capabilities.
All the things you see
available in the pipelines
are really built on
top of operations
that are available in kind of
an ad hoc form within the UI.
So you can do troubleshooting.
You can isolate VMs
that aren't behaving
and take them out
of the group so they
don't take further traffic.
But the important
thing to keep in mind
is that these principles, while
we've demonstrated them here
so far with virtual
machines, apply equally well
to a world built on containers.
So we've been hard at work.
And we have now an
integration with Kubernetes
far enough along that I can
demonstrated it here live.
And again, no backup video,
so it could get real exciting.
But the integration's
in quite solid shape.
Everything I'm showing
you here is checked in.
So I'm running what's
committed at head basically.
So anything we're
doing here, you
can easily try out on your own.
So I'll kick off
the demo and then
I'll explain a bit more about
the Kubernetes integration
because I don't want
to run out of time.
So I'll just get it
going then we'll--
So this is another simple
hello world application.
This time it's in Go
instead of Java or Groovy.
So I'm changing
a version number.
And then I have an
endpoint that'll
let me see the version
when it comes up.
So we'll be able to
determine that we actually
got the correct version.
So I changed one simple file.
So I went into this
very simple application.
I changed the version
string that'll
be returned from slash version.
And then I basically tagged
and pushed that container image
to a Docker registry.
So in this case I'm running
using Google Container
Registry.
It's like a hosted
Docker registry,
makes it easy to
configure the credentials.
But the import things
that all I did was just
tag it and push it.
I didn't do anything else.
The integration between
Spinnaker and Kubernetes
relies on a few
different things.
The first, you need
a Kubernetes cluster.
So in this case, as we get into
the demo, it will become clear.
But we're running against
Google Container Engine.
It just makes it easy to set up.
But any Kubernetes
cluster that you have,
whether it's on-prem
or on AWS or using GKE,
it'll work exactly the same.
You just add a cluster endpoint
and credentials to access it.
So the integration needs
a Kubernetes cluster,
credentials to access
it, and it needs
to know where to
pull images from.
For that sample application,
I'm using Google Container
Registry.
So I configured my Kubernetes
account within Spinnaker
to pull my Google
Container Registry account.
So it's just looking
in those repositories.
But what it's doing is
polling at some interval.
And any time it sees a
changed to any image,
it pumps an event
into Spinnaker.
And then if I have a
pipeline configured
to trigger from a change to any
image in my container registry,
it'll kick off that pipeline.
And you can do the
things you'd expect.
You can make it listen for
a specific tag or all tags.
You can have it listen for
changes to multiple images.
All of that works quite well.
In this case we're
keeping it simple.
It's one image.
It's all within my same
Google Cloud Platform account.
And I'm relying on
the hosted services
to make it a bit easier.
So I mentioned, there are
different kinds of triggers.
We'll dig into
the pipeline here.
So this Docker triggered
basically says,
any push to a Docker
registry-- and that's
the registry to
poll-- that involves
a change to that
repository-- in this case,
I didn't specify tag,
so any tagged image
will kick off this pipeline.
If it detects that change,
it kicks off the pipeline.
So what does the
pipeline look like?
It's quite simple.
There's a deploy stage.
And we didn't look at this yet.
I could show you what the
Deploy Wizard looks like.
This looks pretty similar
from cloud platform
to cloud platform.
The details differ a little
bit, but the overall flow
is quite consistent
between platforms.
It's not a pure abstraction
where every platform has
to fit the exact shape,
but the experience
is consistent from
platform to platform.
So there's all the
details you'd expect.
You have to choose what
containers you want to deploy.
And it's just
polling the registry.
So whatever's available
in your registry
is what's available in the UI.
You can associate it
with load balancers.
Now all of these constructs
map so the proper Kubernetes
construct.
So load balancers
map to services.
There's server groups.
And we explain on GCE, these
are managed instance groups.
On AWS, there are
autoscaling groups.
On Kubernetes, these are
replication controllers.
And whereas on the different
virtual machine integrations
we described each
server group deploys
VMs that really contained a
single instance, the server
groups in this case
are application
controllers deploying
pods that could
contain multiple containers.
So this demo, we're
just applying one.
But you can deploy as
many containers as make
sense for your pod.
And so on.
And you can specify all the
resource settings, environment
variables, mount volumes.
All the things you'd expect
to be able to do, you can do.
And the nice thing
about this is that we're
providing a consistent
experience across platforms
and we're hiding a
lot of the complexity.
You can always drill down,
get to all the details.
But you don't have
to bury yourself
in all that complexity.
So your sort of day
to day workflows, you
deploy your changes
into production
is made quite a bit easier.
So we have a deploy stage, and
then we have a disable server
group stage.
And in this case, all Kubernetes
relies on selectors or labels,
so that's what we're doing.
We're not disassociating
it from a load balancer.
We're changing a label such
that the services selectors
don't pick up those
replication controllers.
And then again, a
manual judgment stage.
And I've been just as
thorough with my testing
as I was before.
It says validated.
We want to validate
the test cluster.
Same thing.
And we'll just click
OK when we get to it.
And then the last
thing is a resize.
So let's go back.
Let's see how far it got.
So it did the deploy.
It did the disable.
And now it's waiting
for my judgment.
I have very good judgment.
I'll say it worked great.
Now it's doing a resize.
So let's take a look
at the cluster view
while this kicks off.
So this is the cluster.
And I'll explain a
bit more about what's
on the screen in a second,
because there's one
other thing I want to call out.
But you can see that grayed
out cluster at the bottom.
That was deployed previously.
It was disabled.
So it's grayed out.
The one that's resizing now,
when it was first deployed,
it had one container.
We said test it.
Once we're happy with the
test, we'll scale it up.
In this case I scaled
it to 400 containers.
And it'll take a
minute or so and then
you'll see they'll
all turn green.
But there's one other
interesting thing on this page.
So at the bottom we have
a Kubernetes cluster.
And in the middle we
have a GCE cluster.
And then at the top we
have an Amazon cluster.
And they all look quite similar.
All the health checking
works quite similarly.
Sort of the high level
view looks about the same.
But then as you
start to drill down,
you can see there
are differences.
And you can get to the
details if you want.
So you can see obviously
the zones are different.
And you could see the VPC
information, and so on.
And there are context
menus and things everywhere
that makes sense for the
selected resource type.
So that should be deployed.
So this is cruising right along.
OK, so it's done.
The Kubernetes stuff
works very well.
It's very fast, kind of snappy.
And one nice thing is we
expose the YAML everywhere.
So if you actually want
to see the YAML that's
backing all these
resources, it's quite easy
to drill down on any one.
If I could have the
presentation laptop please?
So you can see how it maps.
We covered the GCE one.
And then this is how these the
Kubernetes integration maps
down to the key
Kubernetes resources.
So we'll come back to the
triggering in a second.
But you're deploying Docker
images or container images
in this case.
You're not deploying
groups of VMs.
You're just applying
replication controllers.
And instead of containing
VMS, they contain pods.
And pods can contain
multiple containers.
We support all of
that throughout.
And the same thing.
You can again apply those
same first class operations.
So you can do a
red-black deployment
or a blue-green deployment
on Kubernetes resources.
And the triggering
is just what we said.
Instead of looking for
necessarily a Jenkins job
to complete, you could pull
on something like Docker hub.
And when you see a change
pushed, you kick off your job.
OK, so status.
This was open sourced
November 16, 2015.
Quite comprehensive
support for Amazon's EC2
and for Google Compute Engine.
Pivotal has been adding
Cloud Foundry support.
It's quite far along.
Microsoft Azure has as
a team working on it.
We meet weekly.
We're all working out
in the open together.
It's been pretty
interesting trying
to learn from each other.
And we see kind of
the same struggles
as we all come up to speed.
But they're coming
along and they have also
some sort of developer
conference coming up
where they're going to be
presenting Spinnaker as well.
So again, it supports a bunch
of different cloud platforms.
So the Kubernetes support,
everything I showed today
is checked in.
I'm working basically from head.
These are from the
published Debian packages.
I just built an image
using the hosted scripts.
This is being used in
production at Netflix.
There are quite a few
other companies using it.
We have some internal folks
at Google using it as well.
And we have a thriving
open source community.
There's a Slack chat room
that there must be a thousand
or close to a thousand users
now in a general channel there.
We have some tags
on Stack Overflow.
And obviously there are eight or
nine or 10 or more GitHub repos
that host the various
services and all the umbrella
projects that control it all.
If you want to give it a shot,
on the Google Cloud Launcher,
we have a quite easy
to use solution.
It's a couple of clicks,
no configuration.
You'll be up and running
within your GCP project.
And there are tutorials
on our Spinnaker.io page
and on our cloud
solutions page that
will sort of point in
the right direction.
We'll all be available
out in the playground.
We're not sure where
that is, but they
said to say that after this.
And Andy brought some of
these guys from Netflix.
So direct all the hard
questions to them.
And thank you all for coming.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]